la chronique échos le jeudi avec alice
gastines bonsoir à licence phare eyfried
alors ce soir aux alentours la chronique
j'ai choisi de vous parler du travail et
du handicap à l'occasion du 3eme
handicafé 1 qui se déroule à montigny
demain matin françois bellini bonsoir
vous êtes vice président de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de livin val
d'oise pardon il vous est aussi
président de la commission aménagement
alors le principe de ce handicap est
organisée à l'initiative de la chambre
de commerce est en fait de se faire
rencontrer des employeurs et puis des
personnes handicapées qui sont à la
recherche dans l'emploi tout à fait
peut-être vous expliquer les contraintes
liées aux entreprises aujourd'hui
lorsqu'une entreprise à plus de 20
salariés
elle est dans l'obligation d'avoir plus
de 6% minimum de personnes handicapées
au sein d'entreprises semi ciel ne le
fait pas elle doit payer
elle doit payer taxes d'amande voilà on
va appeler ça une taxe est une taxe qui
correspond par personne handicapée
manquante correspond à 400 fois le smic
horaire pour les entreprises de 20 199
salariés et la plupart des entreprises
payent cette taxe alors paradoxalement
on peut croire que les entreprises ont
du mal à embaucher des personnes
handicapées
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que 61% des
entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
répondent à la demande des personnes
handicapées d'embauché personnes
handicapées ça veut dire que c'est
dissuasif
lamonde la halle 6 c'est dissuasif c'est
effectivement dissuasif ces mêmes
il ya même un effet accélérateur c'est
que si pendant une période de trois ans
vous n'êtes toujours pas dans la
légalité
vous passez de 400 fois le smic horaire
ou 500 fois le smic horaire suivant la
taille de l'entreprise à 1500 donc ça
fait quatorze mille un peu plus de 14000
euros par personne handicapée manquante
ou ce qui commence à faire des montants
très importants
donc ça devient disposif donc pour aider
ces entreprises la chambre de commerce a
mis en place handicafé tout à fait
le principe dans des cafés est
relativement simple on compare d'un
constat en fait il m'est arrivé dans une
vie précédente d'être chargé de mission
handicap au sein de la cgpme des
yvelines et le morro les ted de
sensibiliser les entreprises de leur
expliquer qu'il fallait rembourser des
personnes handicapées qu'ils avaient des
contraintes il est possible pour cent
c'est un peu moins mais j'avais un
retour régulièrement en dix ans mais
j'ai aucun problème pour embaucher des
personnes handicapées
contrairement à ce que je pensais à la
base donc les infrastructures on peut
imaginer que c'est exactement donc les
entrepreneurs avait non pas des
difficultés vouloir embaucher
il avait des difficultés pour trouver
les personnes voire même effectivement
avoir les problèmes d'aménagement du
poste de travail donc fort de ce contact
de ce constat il faut mettre en place
des outils permettant d'aider les
entreprises à trouver des personnes
handicapées et des personnes handicapées
à trouver des entreprises bien entendu
donc le principe dans des cafés c'est ça
c'est dans un contexte convivial
oui là ce sera public
donc le but du jeu est vraiment d'être
dans un contexte non stressant convivial
sympathique où on va mettre en face des
personnes qui recherchent un travail qui
mettent à disposition leurs cv façon
visualiser et de l'autre côté la liste
des postes proposés par les entreprises
et essayer la mesure du possible de
rendre cohérent la demande et l'offre
voilà et ça fonctionne déjà eu des
précédents ça fonctionnait non seulement
ça fonctionne alors à la base c'est
l'adapt qui a mis ça en place
en 2007 qui a démarré cette opération
ils ont démarré dans l'essonne si je me
souviens bien
et en 2010 on a commencé ça ici sur le
sens saint quentin et en 2010 on avait
déjà cinquante et une entreprise qui
venait il y avait 180 personnes
handicapées qui venait donc ça marche et
ça a été reconduit en 2011 quand les
gens viennent mais ce que derrière en
tout cas ça débouche sur des embauches
alors justement en 2011 effectivement on
a été en été plus loin puisque il ya eu
45 recrutement larron là c'est du
concret on sait exactement et 45
recrutement c'est ses 45 personnes
handicapées qui s'entend dans le tri
dans dix-sept entreprises tout à fait
alors vous le disiez les entreprises ce
n'est pas par mauvaise volonté un
parfois séparément que de deux candidats
aussi nous sommes allés demander aux
saint quentinois de quelle manière la
question du handicap était abordé dans
leur entreprise on écoute leur réponse
oui je pense que c'est parfaitement bien
géré et oui peut-être n'ont que quelques
petites accommodation compatible avec
l'un des leur handicap mais sinon ça se
passera très bien
ben écoute et on n'a pas de personnel
handicapé au sein de notre entreprise
néanmoins je pense qu'ils auraient pas
de problème d'accessibilité dans la
mesure où un autre immeuble est
accessible
qui un ascenseur donc je pense qu'il n'y
a pas de problème s'était aménagé
normalement tout est aménagée pour les
handicapés on en a eu une personne qui
était qui prenez les transports tous les
jours on n'a pas d'exemple justement
mais si un jour c'est le cas je suis pas
sûr c'est en plus si on est muni de sas
et les sas on rentre debout mais un
fauteuil roulant ne passera jamais on a
eu des personnes handicapées au niveau
de l'aménagement
oui l'ascenseur les ports sont larges
aujourd'hui on n'a pas je crois de
travailleurs handicapés dans la société
par contre dans le quotidien de notre
activité on travaille dans le recyclage
ont fait appel à beaucoup de sociétés
d'insertion qui font parfois appel à des
travailleurs handicapés
on l'entend la plupart des gens sont
prêts à accueillir des travailleurs
handicapés si ce n'est déjà fait est-ce
qu il ya aussi un travail à faire auprès
des salariés alors oui bien entendu ça
se prépare ça se prépare avec les
salariés et je dirais même que la
plupart du temps les salariés sont
impliqués dans le suivi et l'aide de la
personne qui vient de rentrer il ya un
petit détail également c'est côté
entrepreneur une fois qu'il a personne
handicapée est embauchée là il ya quasi
totalité de satisfaction des
entrepreneurs sur la qualité et les
compétences de ces personnes handicapées
qui vont vraie volonté de travailler et
qui sont vraiment reconnu dans
l'entreprise je vais juste faire une
parenthèse pendant qu'on écoutait le
micro-trottoir vous nous avez bien dit
le handicap c'est pas seulement être en
fauteuil roulant tout à fait ainsi c'est
un point important pour les chefs
d'entreprise qui va l'embaucher pas ce
qu'ils disent est effectivement on
parlait d'aménagement l'aménagement et
tous types ça peut être effectivement le
fauteuil roulant qu qui elle ce qu'on
pense en premier lieu mais ça peut être
des personnes qui entend mal ça peut
être des personnes qui voient mal ça
peut être simplement une adaptation de
postes de travail au niveau de la
visualisation de l'ordinateur avec des
caractères plus gros donc c'est pas
toujours quelque chose qui est visible
non plus à le problème de mal de dos par
exemple est très souvent une raison donc
dans les cas et ça ne se voit pas donc
eu des difficultés mais aussi pour
l'employeur ces deux d'avoir
de savoir que les personnes certaines
personnes sont déclarées comme personnes
handicapées puisqu'ils n'ont pas
l'obligation de le déclarer
donc c'est la personne qui le décide
après comment est-ce que ça se passera
demain concrètement est ce que les
personnes handicapées en recherche dans
pop à venir ou est-ce qu'il fallait
s'inscrire au préalable
non ils peuvent --peu venir certains se
sont inscrits auprès à un préalable mais
l'objectif c'est d'être le plus ouvert
possible le plus convivial possible
possible et d'avoir la liste de toutes
les
les postes proposés donc ils sont tous
la bienvenue ils peuvent tous
effectivement visualiser et aller voir
les entreprises
j'ai une toute dernière question avant
de vous libérer françois bellini est ce
qu'il existe des aides pour les
entreprises aussi parce qu'on parlait
d'aménagement et d'aménager le poste de
travail à l'ordinateur des choses comme
ça pour les personnes malvoyantes il ya
des aides financières
il existe une entité l'état qui
s'appelle âgées fip qui est une entité
qui aide à l'aménagement des postes de
travail et tout
tout salarié peut avoir son poste de
travail aménagés et l'agefi participe
grandement à la mise en place et au
paiement de ces aménagements
oui parce que c'est cette agence qui est
qu'ils récupèrent en fait les taxes
récoltées auprès des entreprises qui
n'auraient pas 6% de ça c'est
normalement un cycle vertueux
les taxes sont payés et doivent
participer doivent aider à participer ou
postes de travail merci d'être venu sur
le plateau elle se rappelle peut-être
l'addax de 7 de celle handicafé oui ça
se tient donc demain matin à skywest à
montigny à partir de 9h30 de leur compte
9h30 jusqu'à midi quoique la matinée